they arrive stuffed into car boots
and on the back seats they're taking
some terrible hits trying to stop the
Russian troops entering the Ukrainian
Capital laid out on already blood-soat
stretches
the soldiers have just been shelled on a
front line which is creeping ever closer
to Keith
and it's the nearest hospital now
entirely turned over to dealing with the
war wounded
these aren't Army Medics they're the
towns doctors and nurses who two weeks
ago were dealing with births and bone
breaks
now they're plunged into a new world
spent trying to save the lives of
soldiers and civilians torn apart by
bombs and bullets
it's World War III it's world war three
and it could be stopped here or it could
move through the whole earth
please help us to stop this world
they are shell-shocked and shaking and
so far the politicians peace talks have
got nowhere
hospitals are protected locations under
international law but no one here trusts
that to be observed yet there's an
astonishing resilience and perhaps a
realization they have no option
it's not difficult for us to fight he
tells us we're defending our land and
will continue to protect it but then he
delivers a rousing call not just to his
fellow Ukrainian men and women but also
the rest of the world everyone has to
stand together he says
glory to Ukraine our army will win
this is on the northwest edge of the
capital and we found multiple vehicles
and homes which had been hit apparently
indiscriminately
there seems to be no shortage of Lucky
escapes he was on duty as an emergency
worker
his house five houses right here there
are thousands of lives abruptly halted
by this war
pets abandoned in the rush to keep out
of the way of the rockets and bombs
families who've upped and left
everything just to try to survive
there's a constant sound of artillery
and shelling going on and you can see
the devastation that some of the attacks
have already had we know according to
the locals here that the Russians are
only a few kilometers down the road and
this is the constant backdrop
so those who can't or won't leave live
in a shadowy underground World below the
booming War sounds
about half of the capital's population
has fled the city according to the mayor
we're just waiting for victory for
everything to be good again she says and
trying not to cry
these are the bravest of women tending
to some of the community's most
vulnerable and most frightened
secretaries we've already learned how to
tell the difference between our side
shooting and the enemies Natalia tells
us we can identify everything and we're
just trying to keep everyone calm
they're already living under siege here
with sons and partners fighting and
their homes bombed it says we're trying
for sure this is a crime and Putin has
to be punished she tells us
those fleeing include a former British
soldier who'd been living in butcher had
to pass through Russian troops to escape
and saw dozens of Civilian targets had
been attacked
[Music]
people have been marking their vehicles
with the Ukrainian or the Russian worth
a child on their vehicles if they have
children a bunch of those Vehicles were
also destroyed with children markings
they're engaged in the fight of their
lives to stop the Russian troops
advancing any further but their
president's warning much more of their
blood will be spilled unless his Nation
gets international Military Support Alex
Crawford Sky News on the edge of the
capital Kiev